I'm more than halfway through my time
and more place the food's better the
waiters have improves but without
adjusting was all a bit pointless there
are three days of the year when every
ration should be full even purple ones
New Year's Eve Valentine's Day and
Mother's Day and Sunday is Mother's Day
ritual Nick they'll be taking bookings
trying to pull back some money I should
be pleased but I'm terrified
I thought we'd struggle with 150 but 181
it's making me feel worse is good
ambitious but just you know what we're
trying to do and turn this place around
take an upper-division yeah yeah you
getting customers in here but and what
worries me is that you know they still
not turned on they know feeding off more
than I can chew
I'm as worried as Andy but I have an
idea
roast chicken just like your mother used
to make but with a twist
carve at the table to take pressure off
the kitchen chicken before you for the
change you've cut a chicken before many
many so many many easy everyone's going
to learn including the owners Jason you
thought you were coming down here for a
round of golf
no you're not I want you to do a chicken
family yeah I brought in JC one of my
best maitre d's he knows everything
there is to know about service and about
carving and chicken I mean one of so so
classic first cut off the legs then
separate the drumstick from the thigh
next cut along the breastbone
keep the knife close to the carcass and
take off the breast I will I will just
be myself just you know speaking
necessarily the skin in the customer can
do it
turn the chicken over
now remove the succulent oyster
underneath that's a nice piece of meat
everyone to practice
yep converging which is the ours first
and then you go to the bread the chicken
has to be carved in three minutes or the
rest of the food will have gone cold
goofily cut the drum off you've got the
fire there tomorrow have to carve in
front of the customers and I'll have to
look better than this